so I hate to start the week with
something so depressing and so negative
and so horrifying but we really need to
recontextualize the embarrassing
humiliating vaccination situation in
which we find ourselves in the United
States uh in a situation where
increasingly the right is focused on
authoritarian Joe Biden because of his
so-called vaccine mandates announced
last week now remember the vaccine
mandates announced last week like for
example if you have over a hundred
employees you need to require a
vaccination from them
or they can just be tested every week so
like there's a pretty simple way not to
have to get vaccinated even in those
cases uh but even still there being
called vaccine mandates and the right is
focused on its authoritarian it's not
and it's illegal and it's not and it's
unprecedented but it's not and all of
this different stuff the context in
which this is happening
is a context in which the United States
here we go is quickly becoming the least
vaccinated wealthy country in the world
the least vaccinated we had all the
vaccines earlier than anybody we created
some of the vaccines at least partially
American companies manufactured the
vaccines we had dibs we had it all and
yet the United States is quickly
declining in vaccinations per 100 people
per capita and will soon be the least
vaccinated of the wealthy countries and
it is for one reason we have
an overwhelming number
of a special breed of ignorant political
extremists whose ignorance has been
channeled could have been channeled into
other things the ignorance has now been
channeled
into thinking they shouldn't get the
vaccine either for political reasons
they don't want to make Joe Biden look
good by getting vaccinated or they don't
trust the vaccine and they've fallen for
other conspiracy theories about it was
rushed or it changes your DNA or it
magnetizes you or it demagnetizes your
wound who knows whatever
we are globally a joke we are so
humiliated but the very people
who are making us be humiliated
aren't paying attention to what's going
on globally anyway and if they were they
wouldn't care they would say those [ __ ]
Europeans who cares if they think what
that we are idiots other countries look
at us and they say guys
send the vaccines to the countries that
want them we have countries where as
soon as we get five you know enough
vaccine supply for five percent of the
population we vaccinate five percent
and then we get to 50 and 55 and on and
on if you have all these anti-vaxx
morons they are saying elsewhere
send us the vaccine so let's look at the
numbers start with the world's seven
richest countries per capita okay that's
Luxembourg Singapore Ireland Qatar
Switzerland uh Norway and the United
States as you see what we're putting a
graph up for our visual audience and I
will describe it to you as you see on
the left side of the graph that's the
U.S that that line that was leading we
started in first place because we had
all the vaccines and we are now tied for
last place with Switzerland and
Switzerland will soon pass us because
they are vaccinating at a faster rate
now even if you say Sir let's look at a
different group of countries this isn't
fair uh yes we are very economically
rich but intellectually we are not a
very rich country because of all these
morons let's look at something else well
even if you look in static countries
with the biggest populations you say
let's look at China India Indonesia
Pakistan Brazil and the United States
the most populous countries you see a
clear Trend where for now we are still
second in per capita vaccination among
the biggest most populated countries but
we have the flattest curve China already
passed us in per capita vaccination
Brazil is just about to pass us India
Indonesia and Pakistan are vaccinating
at far faster rates than the United
States now you could say well David as
they approach our rate of vaccination
they will slow down and they're not
actually going to pass us wrong we've
already seen that not be the case with
the richest countries and there is no
evidence that's going to be the case
with the largest population countries
think about it we made the vaccines we
bought the vaccines we got them earlier
we made them available to anyone who
wants one who wants two and we are still
within could be weeks could be a couple
of months we are going to fall
pathetically behind in vaccinated
percentage of the population relative to
the developed world the wealthiest
countries whatever term you want to
apply relative to the most populated
countries as well now just to show you
just as a reminder because the people
who most want to end all guidelines are
some of the very people who don't want
to get vaccinated just to show you what
vaccines can do you know everybody's
been talking about Israel
Israel was very fast out of the gate but
the truth is vaccination rates in Israel
have slowed down there's like 20
countries that have a higher vaccination
rate than Israel Denmark Denmark is now
I believe it's about 75 percent
vaccinated we're at 53. they've
vaccinated 50 percent more people than
us remember 50 percent more please don't
get confused on the math 75 is 50 more
than 50. they are wide open they have
essentially ended all guidelines I saw a
picture of a concert huge packed venue
no masks and cases continue to decline
in Denmark other countries are really
taking advantage of vaccines as they
become available it is completely
embarrassing and pathetic what is going
on in the United States and it's not
everyone it's the covet anti-vaxxers who
are mostly Republicans that's that's the
reality of it right now
look at some of these U.S states where
we still see under 40 vaccination
Wyoming and West Virginia they're not
even at 40 percent
Idaho Alabama and Mississippi they're at
40 on the dot Idaho just had to call in
the National Guard to help because it's
gotten so bad we covered that story last
week on the bonus show and sadly some of
the very people refusing to take the
vaccine are the ones that say I'm a
patriot
I'm America First think about that what
could be less patriotic than taking a
vaccine that's I'm sorry what could be
less patriotic than not taking a vaccine
that's free
in order to protect your fellow American
citizens and they won't do it they claim
to love their country and they say
America First and yet the most populated
countries are passing Us in vaccination
rate the richest countries are passing
Us in vaccination rate it is a living
nightmare
partially of our own doing now I'm not
saying we created the virus everybody
relax but once we had the tools
we did not take advantage of them the
way other countries are taking advantage
of them and as a result it is going to
be we are going to be sleeping in this
may a bed that to some degree the
Republican anti-vaxx movement has made
for us and um I want to keep talking we
we also have some new data I want to
talk about that's relevant to this